Aujourd'hui je reçois une nouvelle invitée pour la série Dans Son Corps,
elle s'appelle Margot, elle vient évidemment nous parler de sa particularité physique, mais surtout de comment apprendre à vivre avec.
Margot tient la chaîne Vivre Avec sur youtube et elle fait aussi des interventions et des conférences de sensibilisation au handicap.
Salut margot. -Bonjour ! -Est ce que tu peux nous expliquer quelle est ta particularité physique à toi?
Alors, j'ai le syndrome d'Ehlers-Danlos, le SED.
Le syndrome d'ehlers danlos est une maladie génétique rare qui touche le tissu conjonctif
qui soutient l'ensemble de nos organes, mais margot a déjà expliqué tout ça dans une de ses vidéos, je vous mets le liens dans la description,
allez la voir !
Est ce que tu te souviens du moment où tu t'es rendu compte que tu avais ce syndrome?
Alors ça a été très vague parce que j'ai eu trois ans même plus
en fait (depuis ma naissance), mais j'ai vraiment eu deux-trois ans de grosses douleurs inexpliquées et
le médecin que je suis allée voir, qui m'a renvoyé vers le service pour me diagnostiquer
était le... quinzième médecin que j'allais voir pour ces douleurs là et ...
ça a été un processus très lent en fait très vague. J'ai
trouvé des informations sur internet avant qu'on me confirme
que c'était bien ça et en même temps mon diagnostic mon premier diagnostic (parcequ'il y en a eut plusieurs)
a été un diagnostic à demi-mot en me disant: "on a pas de tests génétiques on peut pas être sûr
donc si vous avez des enfants vous poserai des questions si on vous dit que vous avez ça, donc peut-être ce qui est pas du
tout une réponse fiable
donc ça a été très
très vague comme au diagnostic.
T'avais quel âge à peu près?
J'avais 15/16 ans à peu près et j'ai eu mes douleurs
au collège mais je pensais au collège que tout le monde avait ce genre de douleur et pour moi c'était quelque chose de normal et
l'impact sur ma vie était
relativement faible parce que je pensais que c'était quelque chose de que tout le monde avait.
Au lycée par exemple j'étais
déscolarisés plusieurs mois chaque année, et en terminale j'allais encore peut-être un jour sur 3 donc j'avais la chance d'être en internat ce qui fait que j'avais
pas besoin chaque fois de rentrer chez moi tout ça mais
c'était quand même assez embêtant et surtout quand c'est à l'adolescence, c'est un moment où se construit,
un moment où le rapport aux autres est super  important
c'était délicat à gérer...
Les principaux symptômes sont des douleurs qui peuvent toucher un peu tout le corps, une souplesse extrême des membres, de la fatigue et une peau très fragile.
Est ce que tu peux expliquer un peu progressivement comment tu es passée des douleurs aux autres signes?
Ca a commencé
je devais avoir peut-être sept ou huit ans et en fait j'ai été suivie dans un centre pour enfants
tous les tous les six mois j'avais un rendez-vous pour
surveiller mon hyper laxité et est surveiller ma scoliose
qui en fait s'est révélé ne pas être une scoliose mais une déformation en plus dû à l'hyperlaxité.
et j'ai fait ça jusqu'à
jusqu'au milieu du collège où tous les six mois j'avais mon rendez vous et donc
dès petite, j'ai pris l'habitude de me déshabiller devant des médecins de ne pas poser de question de les laisser toucher mon corps de les
laisser critiquer mon corps aussi parce que à la puberté j'ai pris du poids comme absolument toutes les filles à la puberté
et a été critiqué donc voilà déjà
et ensuite j'ai eu des douleurs au dos qu'on m'a  diagnostiqué , enfin diagnostiqué c'est
un grand mot,  comme douleur de croissance
j'avais très souvent des entorses en cm2 j'ai pas pu faire une seule séance de... Si j'ai fait une
séance de sport justement une séance de judo de l'année parce que j'avais des béquilles tout le temps j'avais des entorses mais en permanence
au collège j'avais de plus en plus de douleur j'étais très très fatiguée je rentrais du collège à 6 heures le soir je m'endormais en fait,
et je me faisais pourrir comme du poisson pourri parce que j'allais pas prendre ma douche, parce que
ça c'est normal: quand tu rentres du collège tu fais tes devoirs tu fais ta douche
ben non moi je m'endormais.
Je dormais une heure deux heures tous les soirs
et ensuite au lycée
je suis partie en internât en bretagne avec le climat qu'on connaît à la bretagne
( j'adore la bretagne je suis à moitié bretonne j'ai passé 3ans là bas)
mais il pleut quand même vachement et j'étais tout au bout de la bretagne
donc... horrible. Pour les articulations c'était pas bien du tout et je pense que c'est en partie pour ça que j'ai
commencé à avoir vraiment très mal
et c'est des douleurs qui m'empêchait d'aller en cours, qui me faisait pleurer. je pouvais pas me tenir assise plus d'un quart d'heure
je
savais pas ce que c'était donc avec les médecins de l'infirmerie on est passé par tous les stades :
-Par le pourquoi tu fais semblant d'avoir mal ?
- par le je sais  pas ce que tu as.
-par le bon ben va t'allonger, reviens après
J'ai été envoyé aux urgences j'ai été envoyé voir
littéralement des dizaines de médecins différents
Pendant les vacances de la première à la terminale j'ai enfin eu mon diagnostic
ce qui fait que j'ai fait une seule année au lycée avec mon diagnostic
ce qui est pas énorme quand t'as pas de diagnostic à donner aux profs
les améliorations sont plus compliquées à avoir parce que t'as pas de diagnostic donc tu pourrais faire semblant
et j'ai été diagnostiqué au lycée enfin
et c'est venu comme un soulagement en fait.
Beaucoup de personnes pourraient se dire que quand on a une maladie chronique,
qui en plus n'a pas de traitement, parce que tout ce que j'ai c'est du palliatif c'est pour améliorer les douleurs
je veux dire,  c'est pour rendre les douleurs plus faibles,
c'est pour m'aider à plus me déplacer,
diminuer la fatigue, mais c'est pas quelque chose qui vient traiter le gène en fait,
puisqu'on ne l'a pas encore découvert
et quand j'ai le diagnostic c'est vraiment tombé comme un soulagement parce que j'avais enfin un mot j'avais une preuve
du fait que j'avais pas bien alors
on ne devrait pas avoir besoin de preuves pour avoir des aménagements et pour avoir le droit des tiers temps pour avoir le droit à des
'fin ça devrait suffire de voir qu'on va pas bien qu'on a l'air d'avoir très mal . Mais bon, il fallait une preuve
et je me suis dit mais
c'est pas quelque chose que j'invente
c'est quelque chose qui est réel, c'est quelque chose qui pour l'instant ne guérira jamais parce que on n'a pas les avancées
les avancées médicales pour ça mais c'est réel et je peux trouver d'autres gens qui vivent la même chose
et je peux trouver une communauté
et ça fait du bien .
C'est un grand soulagement d'avoir mon diagnostic.
Les traitements existent pour atténuer les symptômes mais on ne guérit jamais du syndrome d'ehlers danlos
Et
en pratique dans ta façon de te déplacer tu parles tu parlais des douleurs là aujourd'hui tu es en béquilles
Tu te  déplace pas tout le temps en béquilles, tu peux tu peux raconter un peu comment ça se passe dans ton quotidien?
je me déplace de façon différente j' utilise plein d'aide à la mobilité. Ca va de
juste des chaussures et je vais sur mes deux jambes,
à je mets des attelles,
j'utilise une béquille,
j'utilise deux béquilles
j'utilise un vélo mais je peux pas marcher ( je peut pédaler mais je peux pas marcher),
j'utilise un fauteuil roulant ...
c'est immense comme ...
- ça c'est quoi? c'est la douleur qui définissent ton mode de déplacement?
- Alors il ya plein de paramètres. Il y a le fait que j'ai des douleurs
et que c'est quelque chose qui fatigue, qui enlève des capacités de concentration... enfin c'est
Je pense qu'il faut comprendre c'est que les douleurs chroniques c'est pas comme: on a une fois mal au ventre.
C'est on a mal au ventre tout le temps, tout le temps, tout le temps
et autant quand on a un petit mal de tête pendant une heure c'est pénible
mais ça passe quand on a mal à la tête pendant deux jours d'affilée déjà ça commence à peser donc
ça prend une toute autre dimension
donc j'essaye d'éviter ça. Ca peut être pour diminuer les douleurs ça peut être aussi pour
épargner mes articulations pour pas me blesser parce que si je me blesse ça veut dire encore plus de temps de récupération
encore plus de douleur encore plus de limitations dans mes mouvements
ça peut être aussi parce que j'ai des choses de prévues
et qu'il faut pas que je déclenche une crise
parce que je peux forcer jusqu'à un certain point mais ça veut dire qu'ensuite je faire une journée dans mon lit à pleurer avoir mal
et maudire tous les gens qui m'entourent ce qui n'est pas idéal
donc parfois j'utilise le fauteuil
je peux marcher
mais j'utilise le fauteuil parce que je sais que ça va permettre de faire plus, ça permet de faire ce que je veux
et ça va me permettre toujours de travailler
je vais passer en deux jours où j'irai mal
mais ça va pas être une semaine, ça va pas être deux semaines, ça va pas être six mois
donc c'est en fonction des douleurs que j'ai de la fragilité de mon corps et aussi de ce que je peux me permettre de prendre
comme jours de douleurs très étrange dit comme ça mais c'est ...
faut que je voie par rapport à mon planning en fait c'est toute une organisation
- et tout à l'heure tu parlais des gens qui te disais
potentiellement "oui pourquoi tu fais semblant machin etc"  est-ce que ça, c'est quelque chose que
les gens comprennent ou qu'il faut que tu expliques?
Le fait que parfois tu as rien, parfois t'as une béquille, parfois t'es en fauteuil ?
j'imagine que ça doit
interloqués les gens parfois
- oui énormément et j'ai déjà eu,
même en étant dans mon fauteuil roulant,
et sans m'être levé devant la personne j'ai déjà eu un vigile qui m'a attrapée en demandant de me justifier sur le fait que j'utilise un fauteuil
parce que ça se voyait pas que j'étais handicapé alors que j'étais dans mon fauteuil roulant quand même
et surtout que c'était un vigile... je sortais d'un centre commercial pour rentrer dans le RER. C'était le vigile du centre commercial
qui est censé regarder que les gens qui rentrent et c'est
plein de petites choses comme ça qui vont arriver au quotidien en fait et
c'est épuisant de toujours expliquer de toujours dire ben voilà il faut il faut que tu me fasses confiance en fait parce que c'est ça
c'est
il faut que tu me fasses confiance parce que je peux pas te prouver que j'ai absolument besoin d'utiliser ces aides là à ce moment là
il faut que tu me fasses confiance c'est moi qui me connaît et faut que tu comprennes faut que tu acceptes
et ça va pousser aussi à faire un tri dans mon entourage
en me dissant:  il ya certaines personnes qui ne comprennent pas,
qui comprendront peut-être avec le temps, mais j'ai pas cette énergie là.
Déjà mon énergie est limité
je n'ai pas cette énergie là à dépenser
pour expliquer et le fait de faire des vidéos ça m'aide beaucoup parce que c'est un
c'est un support que je peux envoyer aux gens sans avoir directement à passer mon énergie dans l'interaction en fait
et j'en parlais avec
ma marraine un repas de famille en face aux croisés et on parlait plein de choses et un moment on s'est dit mais en fait
mes vidéos c'est trop bien dans notre relation parce que comme ça ça te permet de savoir
les difficultés que je peux avoir tu t'adaptes tu connais tout
et on passe pas les 10 h, enfin on passe pas les cinq heures du repas de famille à parler de maladie.
et on parle de ce qui se passe dans  nos vies, de nos projets, de tout ça et
ça fait un très bon support d'explication en fait pour que les gens
puissent voir tout ça de leur côté et que je sois pas tout le temps dans cette cette explication et
après , il faut toujours que des gens ramènent leur expérience
et leur disent "oui mais tu sais j'ai connu une personne qui faisait semblant,
donc c'est pour ça que je me pose des questions" ...
c'est épuisant.
J'ai déjà une maladie qui fatigue et qui fait mal
je vais pas m'en rajouter...
- là tu parlais de tes vidéos et de ce que ça t'apporte
dans ton parcours est ce que tu sais ce qui t'a vraiment aidé à vivre avec ton syndrome?
- je dirais que principalement c'est d'en parler parce que
c'est une chose de réfléchir et d'y penser seul mais si au bout d'un moment on n'a pas d'élément nouveau
on va voir que les points négatifs,
que ce qui va pas...
Le fait que l'on va jamais guérir le fait qu'on a extrêmement mal le fait que personne nous comprend...
Tout ça. Eet le dire à voix haute, c'est aussi... Déjà
trouver les mots qui vont toucher les gens en face. Donc mine de rien c'est le reformuler
parce qu'il faut que les gens puissent nous comprendre.
C'est aussi échanger avec d'autres personnes voire
d'autres côté. Voir les améliorations que certaines personnes ont pu amener dans leur quotidien. Voir
des astuces tout bête qu'on s'échange, des choses pour diminuer les douleurs,
des répliques qu'on a pour casser les proches qui vraiment bout d'un moment il y en a marre, et on trouve des réplique du tac
au tac pour juste les casser et avoir 5 minutes de répit, et c'est ça fait énormément bien le fait d'avoir une communauté en ligne
et je ne parle pas communauté au sens de
je suis vidéaste, j'ai ma communauté.
Mais vraiment au sens de : on a des maladies chroniques ou alors on a des symptômes
qui se ressemblent et on va pouvoir échanger nos expériences et on va pouvoir
parfois juste râler en disant là c'est bon, y'en a marre, je viens de finir une journée c'était épuisant,
dans les transports en commun personne m'a laissé place assise, je me suis blessé et là je vais commencer une crise.
J'en ai marre.
D'avoir des communautés comme ça où on peut parler à des gens qui nous comprennent et
se lâcher
et ça fait énormément de bien
- Aujourd'hui dans ton quotidien,
(même si t'as développé tout un tas de stratégies d'adaptation) c'est quoi le plus pénible pour toi?
- Premièrement je dirai juste
à mon niveau et en ce qui me concerne, juste moi, sans compter les personnes autour, je pense que c'est la douleur parce que
autant j'ai toujours mal mais il ya des moments où c'est pire que d'autres et où
je vais pas réussir à me concentrer, où je vais pleurer, où je vais juste (parce que j'ai mal et je peux rien faire d'autre)
et je sais que je peux rien y faire et qu'il faut juste attendre
et parfois j'ai des moments où j'ai des crises de douleurs telles que je peux presque plus respirer.
Et ça dure
sur quelques heures souvent, je sais que ça va passer mais quand tu es dedans
à certains moments j'ai juste envie de mourir et ça paraît énorme à dire comme ça
c'est pas une exagération.
Ca m'arrive peut-être tous les 3/4 mois
j'ai ces grosses crises de douleur
c'est pas agréable du tout.
Et quand on en sort, il y a ce côté "a ben en fait, ça allait, j'ai survécu "
et quand ça revient on sent la douleur arriver là on se dit, a non, c'est bon, c'est fini
c'est fini ma vie est terminée.
et ma deuxième réponse est:  les personnes autour qui ne comprennent pas.
parce que ça punaises
l'énergie qu'on passe à expliquer
l'énergie qu'on passe à se dire je vais pas aller à l'affrontement même si
c'est une personne qui comprend pas même si c'est la personne en face qui a tort
c'est épuisant.
Le fait que autour ce soit pas adaptées, que quand je veux sortir avec mon fauteuil roulant
je vais aller acheter une pizza, ya une marche! Je veux commander
une boisson dans un café le comptoir est beaucoup trop haut, je vois pas le menu, le fait que
quand je vais aller faire mes courses au supermarché
l'ascenseur pour descendre au rayon au rayon des fruits et des légumes est cassée :  tu ne mangeras pas ce soir c'est en permanence
c'est en permanence et
derrière les valides qui arrivent en disant où mais il faut arrêter de parler tout le temps de tout handicap
parce que tu n'es pas que ça.
Je suis pas que ça mais dans mon quotidien c'est ce qui me définit
sais ce que je dois prendre en compte pour sortir c'est ce que je dois prendre en compte pour exister donc un moment faut être
cohérent vous rendez l'espace accessible
il faut le faire
- Est-ce que tu as souvenir d'un conseil que quelqu'un t'aurait donné et qui t'a vraiment aidé à
passer un cap ou à
accepter c'e que tu vivais?
- Parfois il faut couper il faut prendre soin de Soi
je pense que c'est aussi
particulier parce que je suis dans une démarche de sensibilisation, de je fait des vidéos? Je fais des interventions en fac
je travaille beaucoup par rapport à ça et parfois je me...
je force trop. Ca me déclenché des crises,  je suis moins efficace mais des
des personnes qui est juste mon arrêté en me disant, Margot maintenant
tu te poses. Tu arrêtes tes mails. On va regarder un film. On va regarder un truc . Tu lis un livre.
tu te calmes. Et t'arrête.
parce que tu peux pas tout rendre parfait d'un coup.Tu pourras peut-être jamais  tout rendre parfait mais
faut arrêter d'essayer parce que tu vas te casser et souvent l'argument qui me
qui me va le plus c'est:  tu arrêtes sinon tu serais moins utile après
alors que on devrait juste pouvoir dire tu prends soin de toi
parce que c'est important mais ça fonctionne pas toujours
mais je pense oui c'est ça juste de se poser parfois de se faire un espace où
on sait qu'on va pas avoir un valide qui va arriver en disant
"oui mais regarde LA c'est accessible arrête de te plaindre..." que un espace
Agréable et protecteur où on peut se ressourcer et c'est super important ne pas l'oublier
notre quotidien est déjà assez compliquée avec tout ça
- Est ce qu'il ya un message qui tient particulièrement à coeur et que tu vas faire passer?
- OUI,c 'est destiné aux personnes qui sont pas malades et qui sont valide quand quelqu'un te dit qu'elle ou il à mal
premier réflexe : tu le crois et tu fais en sorte d'améliorer son quotidien et tu pars pas du principe
que c'est pas vrai, que la personne peut faire des efforts, que c'est
extrêmement lourd à vivre si tu peux être le soutien d'une personne qui va mal
si tu peux être le soutien d'une personne qui a des difficultés au quotidien
alors soit son soutien, tu sera
très certainement une des seules personnes sur lesquelles elle peut vraiment compter et c'est super important qu'on ait ce soutien là
et pour les personnes qui vont pas bien, qui sont malades, qui sont handicapés et c'est
t'as raison d'être en colère et t'a le droit d'être en colère parce que
c'est complètement injuste que le monde nous soit inaccessible et parfois juste c'est nul et
c'est bien de prendre des moments juste pour être énervé. Relâcher tout la  la colère. Franchement ça fait énormément de bien
je parle d'expérience.
- Merci beaucoup Margot
- je t'en prie.